I do not know if you saw this story but
it's been a pretty big in the news
according to the Census Bureau last year
the number of minority babies born in
the United States outnumbered the birth
of white babies for the very first time
yeah this is a it's a major shift for
the country and here to comment on this
is one of our writers Deon Cole Deon
thanks Conan so last year more women
gave birth to minority babies all I can
say is you're welcome ladies
[Applause]
I'm sorry I don't understand yet what do
you mean you're welcome ladies
if sexual bravado Konan okay it's chris
parnell from starting out live Chris I'm
sorry Chris did you say it's sexual
bravado
that's right Conan Dion's implying that
he alone is responsible for creating the
recent increase in minority babies
across the country Dianna was suggesting
that his looks are so irresistible his
love making prowess and sexual stamina
so impressive and his sperm so potent
that he could roam the countryside
tirelessly banging millions of fertile
women to change the course of our
nation's demographic history isn't that
right too young I guess very funny
Deanna and thank you Chris
you